no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single no
seriously guys selena gomez wants you to
know she's like totally cool with her
single status it's a real thing it's
fine
on wednesday the 29 year old triple
threat shared that clip to tick tock
poking fun at her relationship status
while hanging out with a few friends
no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single it's a
real thing it's fine
[Music]
but this is hardly the first time sal
has made fun of herself i hope everybody
enjoys it last month the former child
star brought the lols mocking her dating
life last time i was single i was 24 and
the dating pool was everyone and now
it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that that's
selena lip-synching to this clip of
leslie mann's character in the other
woman gotta give sg props for majorly
committing here last time i was single i
was 24 and the dating pool was everyone
and now it's like a shallow puddle of
age-appropriate men who are old and
gross and i don't want to do that i mean
like the girl really gave it her all
here can someone get selena the emmy
please
thank you
the only murders in the building star
who turns 30 in july
captioned the hilarious clip quote me
walking into my 30s i'm okay with it
though
oh my goodness yeah and back in march
the texas native who previously dated
justin bieber in the weekend was back at
it with this clip i mean i'm just really
trying to holla at you forever how about
me for what you said word holla at me
for what
the caption maybe this is why i'm single
don't believe a damn word
i mean you're pretty
oh you got a nice smile oh
i love your personality
then there was this moment i'm going out
tonight so hide your men not because i
want them but because i don't want to
see a singular man on my outing
yeah selena doesn't need validation from
a man to know she's flawless would you
rate yourself on a scale of one to ten
i'm a ten a ten yeah that's like
flawless though yeah i am flawless
okay so like what
let's be real this time all right so
like on one to ten like for real like
realistically what would you rate
yourself
i'm just so confident i feel comfortable
in my skin you know
and it seems like all that confidence is
paying off for the actress
i'm constantly somebody that likes to
grow and feel like all right what could
i be better at what could i do better at
work
where could my confidence be stronger
season two of her hit series only
murders in the building hits hulu on
june 28th
you're probably wondering when season
two of only murders in the building is
going to hit the airway i was wondering
that too i forgot what else
and it seems safe to say selena had a
blast working with her co-stars steve
martin and martin short i could barely
keep a straight face just hanging out
with them it was so wonderful and i
learned so much being around them
they're legends in their own right but
they've you know they're good people
humble funny kind and professional and
it was just the best
so whether she's laughing with comedy
icons or laughing at herself on
tick-tock no i'm fine
i'm totally fine being single she's
always having fun
[Music]